hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar knockout by a logic
quant and quality on a tiny sample I mix
a few tears of lab roots and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab route the leading scientific social
networking website and provider virtual
events and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning it's brought
to you by Unchained labs if you'd like
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit www.cannainsider.com/careers the
presentation window if you experience
technical problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab at the top right of the presentation
window or report your problem by typing
it into the answer question box located
on the far left of your screen I now
present today's speaker lisa Adamiak PhD
lisa Adamiak is an application scientist
at Unchained labs she is responsible for
supporting new product development for
protein analytical tools by carrying out
proof of concept studies lisa received
her PhD in chemistry from UC san diego
where she synthesized and characterized
biological nanomaterials for debt for
diagnostic applications lisa will now
begin her presentation
Thank You Xavier and thank you all for
attending this webinar today so as many
of you may be familiar with analyzing
biologics can be tricky sometimes pieces
of data can tell a story one way okay
can actually reveal a completely
different story when using accurate
measurements or other complementary
techniques so really break down those
illusions when it comes to your data
analysis whether you need to measure
protein stability get some accurate
quantification or just get some
information about the quality of your
sample unchain Labs has the right tools
for the job
today I'm excited to talk about two of
our products lunatic and stunner
for all of your view visas
quantification needs big or little
lunatic has you covered
big lunatic uses a plate based format
measuring up to 96 samples at a time in
just five minutes
little lunatic on the right here in this
screen uses a chip based format that is
ideal for labs that want to quickly and
routinely measure protein concentration
each of these platforms uses just two
microliters of volume per sample
so how does this work the unique plate
consumable or the chip consumable makes
it all possible
so the consumable uses a dual micro
cuvette system that is connected to an
input well via a microfluidic channel
which you can see here in the diagram
the full uv-vis spectrum is measured
with two path length sizes both point
one and point seven millimeter path
lengths this enables the wide dynamic
absorbance range from point zero three
all the way to 275 OD so really you can
measure wide concentrations of your
protein from 0.02 to 200 mils per mil
after simply dropping the sample into
the input well with a pipette the
capillary forces will guide the sample
into the channel as shown in step 2 this
is where the sample will reside until
the plate is loaded into the lunatik
instrument then the pump in lunatic will
apply a negative pressure to carry the
sample the rest of the way into the
cuvettes
as shown in step 3 and then lunatik
simply reads the sample
let's take an up-close and personal view
of the plate
the notice that each sample is separated
by its own microfluidic channel this
means that there's no risk of cross
contamination between samples and each
well is only used a single time also the
plate can be left up to two hours
unattended before measuring because of
the protection that the plate consumable
offers from evaporation each cuvette has
a fixed optical path length so you know
that your concentration is on the money
every time
lunatic can measure the concentration of
all kinds of samples whether it be a
protein or nucleic acid and whether it's
pure or a mixture lunatic has lots of
different applications that can quantify
the concentration of your sample and
we'll get into some of these in a little
bit
so here's a list of the protein specific
applications on lunatic there are
different types categorized by a
conventional or classical quantification
along with unmixed in standard curve
applications unmixed applications can
quantify your protein in the presence of
other impurities such as nucleic acids
salts or components like a medieval
often used during the purification
process of his tag proteins or if you're
inclined to run colorimetric assays like
the BCA Bradford or Lowry assay the
standard curve applications are right
for you so there's lots of great options
now because of the two paths lane
cuvettes
Linda can measure a large dynamic range
from point O 2 to 200 mix of mil of
protein using just 2 microliters of
sample for really high concentration ID
G's you can actually go higher than this
up to 250 mix per mil with high
throughput and reproducibility the
algorithm for this IgG unmix application
actually extrapolates the shape of the
absorbance curve to be able to measure
these concentrations accurately so you
can use less sample eliminate error with
manual dilutions and you don't need to
worry about cross contamination and all
of this can be done with protein
solutions that are less than 40
centipoise
the fixed path links in the consumer
consumable enable both high precision
and accuracy so the same samples were
measured on both a micro volume reader
with the motor driven path links and a
lunatic consumable measuring or
containing the fixed path links the
other micro volume reader shows a lot of
variation especially at the higher
protein concentrations
whereas lunatik shows pretty accurate
and precise concentrations
unlike other uv-vis readers lunatic
gives the option to perform a wavelength
specific background correction with the
classic a2/ad application so this
background or turbidity correction
enables better accuracy because it uses
an algorithm that takes into account the
light scattered at each wavelength now
if you're using a standard protocol the
single wavelength background correction
method you know may be required so this
application is also available on lunatic
if you need it
you
so why do you this turbidity background
correction
well this turbidity or background
correction is wavelength specific
meaning it takes into account Rayleigh
scattering said in another way shorter
blue wavelengths are scattered more
strongly than longer red wavelengths and
because proteins absorb at the lower or
blue wavelengths we account for the
scatter to yield more precise and
accurate quantification of your protein
molecule and so you could have actually
seen this in the previous slide if I
take a look back here with the same
sample analyzed with the turbidity
correction we actually obtain more
accurate quantification at 2.8 mix per
mil instead of a little bit higher at
3.1 mixed per mil
doesn't only apply to proteins either
with nucleic acid quantification the 80
to 60 application also uses the
turbidity or background correction
there's a lot of variety when it comes
to genomics quantification and similar
to the protein applications lunatik
offers the ability to do classic unmix
or other standard curve type
applications so the unmix is also
available 2d convolute the impurities in
these unmixed applications common
detergents and salts are recognized as
impurities and subtracted from the DNA
or RNA absorbance spectrum
the big advantage of VN mix a 260
application is that it can save a lot of
time over other quantification
techniques such as fluorescent dyes so
you just need to measure directly and
you don't require an lunatik doesn't
require any dilution steps
uv-vis quantification of proteins or
nucleic acids lunatic is really the only
system out there that can measure your
biologics at a high throughput and high
concentrations it uses just 2
microliters of sample and it takes just
five minutes to measure up to 96 samples
you can tack on the end mix applications
and lunatik makes batch concentration
measurements really a no-brainer so now
if we take the power of lunatic and
combine it with a technique known as
dynamic light scattering or DLS we get
stunner
now stunner is the first and only
platform that combines UV vis for
concentration and dynamic light
scattering for sizing done err not only
has all the quantification power of
lunatic it can also assess the particle
size of your sample too it also uses a
plate based format just like big lunatic
measuring up to 96 samples at a time
with just two microliters
so often when working with biologics the
first question that's often asked is how
much protein do I have in this sample
usually followed by is this sample still
good with center these questions can be
answered in a single experiment in one
shot
so let's say I'm in the lab and I want
to check my new batch of protein my
batch of protein from last week and then
a really old batch all of which were
stored in the fridge as I double-check
the concentrations I really want to see
if there are aggregates in the sample
however I don't want to spend a lot of
time doing size exclusion chromatography
to assess the quality because it's
time-consuming
Denner gives me the ability to perform
DLS to check particle sizing and here's
an example of that so if we compare my
good sample i showing AZ average
diameter of about 11 nanometers which is
the expected size for a monoclonal
antibody the PDI or polydispersity index
which I'll describe later shows a very
very monodisperse value less than 0.1
and the concentration is close to what I
expect now if I take a look at my sample
from last week the Z average diameter is
a little bit larger and the PDI or
polydispersity index is also a little
bit larger indicating that there's
something maybe a little heterogeneous
in the sample and you can see that in
this intensity distribution curve that
there's two peaks instead of just one in
the sample now they're both both of
these samples are the same concentration
but DLS or dynamic light scattering is
able to give me information about the
size of the particles in solution and in
some cases it can contain several
aggregated populations so in this case
the sample that's really old in the
fridge is really quite messy even though
it's the concentration that I expect the
dynamic light scattering is showing me
that the Z average is now very large
along with the PDI and so this is
indicating that there's more than one
type of particle in solution
the center plate is actually very
similar in design to the lunes lunes ik
plate in that the microfluidic channels
are also used to connect the two paths
link events to the sample input well
however the Center plate enables
simultaneous uv-vis and Els measurements
so when DLS is measured with
concentration a full plate can be
measured in just one our Center can also
be integrated into robotic platforms for
even higher throughput and the deal
aspects meet industry standards
measuring particle sizes anywhere from
0.32 a thousand nanometers
now some of you may have not used Els
before so I want to go over the
technique quickly so dynamic light
scattering or DLS measures particle
diffusion also commonly called Brownian
or referred to as Brownian motion the
sample is essentially irradiated with a
laser and particles moving in the
solution will scatter the light in all
directions the detector will collect the
scattered light signal over time now all
of this looks like random noise but the
rate of change of the signal or the
diffusion coefficient is going to give
us the information that will relate to
the size of the particles in solution
so take a small protein for instance it
will move fairly quickly and so the
fluctuation in scatter will change over
time fairly rapidly and you can see this
as the intensity of scattered light is
plotted over time it's kind of moving up
and down fairly quickly
a larger particle on the other hand will
move pretty slowly and the intensity
fluctuation actually reflect these
slower movements so if we just transpose
that smaller particle intensity over
time with the larger particle intensity
over time you can actually see if you
start to compare these small time
intervals it's easier to notice rapid
changes for the smaller particle than it
is for the larger particle you will
essentially have to wait a longer amount
of time to see a change in the intensity
of light for a larger particle now what
do you do with all this information so
the way that you get size from this is
that each sample has a unique scatter
profile that's measured over time which
will then be used to to give you a
correlation function shown here each
curve has an Associated diffusion
coefficient when fitted to a single
exponential so that will give you the
important information that you use to
assess the particle size in a sample so
notice here that there's two correlation
functions one for a larger particle and
one for a smaller particle the larger
particle produces a correlation function
that takes a longer amount of time to
decay whereas the smaller particles
intensity scatters light more quickly so
it decays more quickly
the ones the correlation function and
the measured diffusion coefficient is
obtained from from that correlation
function the coefficient the diffusion
coefficient is plugged into the Stokes
Einstein equation shown here so the
Stokes Einstein equation uses the
viscosity and the refractive index of
the solvent at some temperature to
determine the hydrodynamic diameter of
the particle so essentially giving you
the particle size in the sample so the
2017 ISO standard is applied and
centered to analyze all of this math for
you so you can focus on getting the data
that you need
the dynamic light scattering is
super-sensitive technique that can is
really good at picking up on the on
small changes or on this very tiny
presence of very very large aggregates
for example if you take a mixture of
particle sizes five and fifty nanometer
particles in diameter the 50 nanometer
particle diameter will scatter light a
million times more than the five
nanometer particle this is because the
intensity of scattered light is
proportional to the diameter to the
sixth power
this makes DLS really an ideal technique
to detect tiny amounts of large things
now let's take a look at what a
polydisperse sample looks like so this
is a sample with multiple populations of
sizes in solution one smaller around the
eight nanometers in diameter for a
protein and a larger population of
aggregates around 270 nanometers and you
can see this shown in the intensity
distribution
so when the cumulants analysis is
applied to the correlation function
shown on the left the Z average diameter
gives the size somewhere around 38
nanometers
now if you take a look at the mass
distribution shown below in blue you
notice that the smaller peak the eight
nanometer one for the protein is the
main contributor to the light scattered
in the sample however this all comes
back to the intensity scattered light
relationship to the diameter so because
of that diameter to the sixth power you
can see that the larger thing scatters
much much more light so you have two
peaks in the intensity distribution
whereas you have a single peak shown in
the mass distribution
and you can kind of see this reflected
in the correlation function so you can
definitely see that there's two
populations kind of coming from from
inside the correlation shown by these
green lines and that's kind of reflected
in the intensity distribution
so in Center analysis software both
intensity and mass distribution curves
are reported so let's take a look at
this further the intensity weighted
distribution indicates if there are
aggregates in the sample based on the
scattering of the sample the mass
distribution describes the relative
proportion of multiple populations in
the sample so this is quite useful since
the relative proportion of monomer and
aggregates are known for a particular
sample as DLS is very sensitive to trace
amount of aggregates you can actually
see in this particular case that the DLS
can detect less than 1% of larger
particles in solution
Thunder software is very streamlined so
it reports the absorbance spectrum and
dynamic light scattering results like
the correlation function intensity and
mass distributions that we've discussed
before and you can see all of this
directly on the screen you don't need to
be a DLS expert to analyze the data the
results table indicates the
concentration measured at a 284 proteins
and the average hydrodynamics diameters
shown as Z average diameter along with
the parent parameter known as
polydispersity index or PDI as we kind
of discussed before so getting more
insight into that the PDI sheds light on
the heterogeneity of the sample so if a
sample contains more mixtures of
particle sizes the PDI can become quite
large larger than 0.1 in value
this particular protein although the Z
average diameter shows approximately
what you'd expect for a monoclonal
antibody the PDI is approaching 0.12
which indicates that there may be a
small portion of aggregates in solution
now for long-term stability experiments
size of solution chromatography or FCC
is the method of choice to evaluate
percentages of monomer and protein
oligomers like dimers trimers or
higher-order molecular weight aggregates
however it takes a long time to run
samples by a sec with additional time to
equilibrate the columns and run
standards so in this example we ran a
monoclonal antibody on sec that was
stored in a salt formulation at 25
degrees over time and we evaluated the
sample at different time points by a sec
now Center is a pretty complementary
technique to evaluate sample quality
over time especially when it comes to
pre-screening samples prior to running
sec so here Center will likely pick up
the higher-order molecular weight
species as they grow in over time as you
can see
now keep in mind that DLS has a
resolution limit so species like dimers
and tremors are not necessarily likely
to be picked up or detected by GLS
nonetheless the center uv-vis can also
pick up concentration of your protein
and fragments so that you can measure
both quantity and quality as a quick
check prior to running your SCC as
expected looking at the same samples day
to day on stunner Center was able to
pick up the high order molecular weight
species at the same as shown by Sec on
day zero the monoclonal antibody has an
expected diameter of about 11 nanometers
and a small PDI of less than 0.1 so that
this indicates a mono dispersed pretty
clean sample we observe the Z averaged
over time not only increasing so by day
6 day 14 and day 21 we can see the slow
increase we can also see that the PDI
increases over time indicating that
multiple particle distributions are in
the sample now Center is pretty powerful
because it can pick up on these small
changes that you know which samples you
need to run on SCC today or maybe the
ones you can wait on and run sec
tomorrow
not only does Stunner tell you the
quality of the protein it can also
measure the concentration which can
indicate whether you're losing protein
over time so the measured UV UV vis
spectra of these samples indicate that
we're actually losing a bit of our
protein as aggregates are forming and
perhaps precipitating out from solution
now being able to measure both
concentration and DLS simultaneously
makes running colloidal stability
experiments very easy on Stunner you can
actually measure both B to do which is
the second virial coefficient and KD the
diffusion interaction parameter using
both static and dynamic light scattering
loads respectively both b2 to n KD are
actually independently measured values
that describe leak nonspecific
intermolecular interactions of a protein
in solution by measuring a dilution
series of a protein in a formulation the
B to 2 and KT values are obtained and
because the protein concentrations are
measured at the same time you actually
get better accuracy for these values
so these values indicate whether protein
has net repulsive intermolecular
interactions or net attractive
interactions with other protein
molecules in solution this this
information can better can help guide
you to identify better formulations for
your biologic so for example this is
shown here if the B to 2 is greater than
0 has a slope greater than 0 it
indicates a repulsive forces for the
protein molecules in solution but if the
B to 2 slope is less than 0 it can
indicate attractive forces for the
molecules in the solution
measuring accurate concentrations for bt
2 & kt experiments is really key
now all the constants the concentration
of all the dilutions need to be measured
prior to running a DLS experiment to
obtain these parameters which can take a
lot of time Center however measures the
concentration and DLS in a single
experiment saving you both time and
ensuring greater accuracy so if you look
here the b2 to plot for formulation
screen of a therapeutic antibody was
done in about an hour so the formulation
that has no excipient or the formulation
with sucrose proved to be the best
formulations for this monoclonal
antibody
the formulation with arginine or salt
because they're a little bit less
positive in the slope are less optimal
because of this relative magnitude of
the beach to value
finished in the client software on the
center the analysis software opens to
reveal your results so the results from
the b22 and KT experiments are shown and
can be easily toggled between sample
groups of different conditions in
addition you can highlight each sample
to look at the results whether this be
the absorbance spectrum peak diameter or
the bt - value BG - or KT values now all
of these parameters are provided for you
so that you don't have to do the
complicated math to calculate them
Center software is very intuitive to use
so it's accessible to both DLS experts
and novices alike whether it be a baby
to two and Katie experiment or sizing
employ dispersity experiment that you
want to measure your concentration and
DLS results immediately opens and it's
clearly visualized in the center
analysis software you can easily flip
through each replicate in the tree mode
view on the Left panel and toggle
between the absorbance or the DLS
screens shown on the right you can also
customize your reports in the report
settings tab at the top there to explore
exactly what you want to see
it's also convenient to select multiple
replicates on-screen for comparison so
if you want to take a glance at the
absorbance or the intensity distribution
for the whole plate you can easily do
this in the overview tab or also compare
your replicates for each of your
experiments there's many ways to
visualize your data
Center also offers the ability to make
your own application with homebrew this
is an exciting feature on Center which
enables more flexibility in the
experimental if in the experimental
setup and its analysis and we'll talk
about this in a little bit
so in the settings tab for the homebrew
application you have the option to
measure any wavelength of interest
include your DLS measurements and select
a background correction method that best
applies to your samples so here you can
simply select whether you want to
measure protein DNA or RNA you can also
choose your peak filters if you want to
so this is really useful if you have
excipient cin your sample that show
particle sizes around 0.5 nanometers and
if you want to filter these out you can
increase increase the minimum size of
that DLS filter from the default to just
point 3 nanometers up past point 5
nanometers so there's many different
ways that you can actually select your
settings that you want to measure your
data
now by clicking the output tab you can
create an equation and really any
formula that you want that will apply to
your absorbance spectra this could be
concentration which is supplied as a
default formula or average concentration
and standard deviation in this case
we're also interested in calculating the
aggregation index so we're using this
particular equation standard analysis
we'll then use these equations to
calculate aggregation index for our
samples by using these values measured
at a two eighty and a three a three
fifty and using this formula so as shown
here you can supply the units for your
particular formula and you can also
identify the number of digits you want
to see whether it's significant digits
or digits of precision and we really
have this calculator platform here to
make it easy for you to identify the
formula that you want
you can also preview what your data will
look like right before you run the
application so if you decide you want to
make some changes it's easy to click the
back button and define your experiments
and the results exactly the way that you
want and notice here that the result the
formulas that we put in the output list
are shown directly in the results table
including the concentration
so really in this example we stress
tested a monoclonal antibody that is
sensitive to vortex mixing so we then
formulated this protein with and without
detergent pSATS shown in the list on the
left and we subjected it to mixing at
different time points the absorbance
spectrum and Els were both measured on
home brew and the aggregation index of
the samples was calculated using the
home brew app and reported in the table
just as we previewed it so you can
actually see here the aggregation index
for this highlighted sample is reported
below concentration standard deviation
and then aggregation index
plotting all the data together we find
that the more turbid the samples are the
higher the aggregation index you can see
that the formulation with the detergent
the PSAT was successfully able to stop
aggregation add the different mixing
time points while the formulation
without any detergent was not able to
stop aggregation so the aggregation
index essentially peaked around two
hours as you can see in this graph and
what's really neat is that this was
confirmed by DL S which was one on the
same experiment with the same set of
samples so if we look at this a little
bit more closely you can see that the
formulation without the detergent PSAT
showed a very large hydrodynamic
diameter along with a very high PDI
value indicating that the sample was
very poly dispersed with aggregates
present in solution now compare this to
the formula with PSAT you can see that
the sample remained pretty closely
aligned with with time zero for that
same formulation
there's so many great options for you
for your UV vis and DLS measurements
with stunner center has all of the cool
applications that lunatic has but with
the ability to assess particle quality
with GLS whether you want to perform a
quick DLS measurement or use in mix 2d
convolute impurities in your sample
maybe check that your purification
protocol is good or maybe you want to
brew your own custom applications with
homebrew I mean you can do all this in
addition to measuring colloidal
stability for the sample so Center can
pick up on all the small changes like
this so you really know that what you're
measuring in the sample is is what you
want to see
Center software does the heavy lifting
so you don't have to
everything is streamlined from the
application screen the wizard guidance
setup and the data visualization so that
everyone can really use it
for a higher throughput needs both
stunner and lunatic can be used and they
could be fully integrated with liquid
dispensing robots with options with API
the plate format for both lunatic and
center are also compatible with any
pipetting head and for easy sample
tracking each center plate and lunatic
plate are equipped with a barcode so
this is important for integrated systems
that ensure traceability and detection
of the wrong plate or maybe random plate
loading
you can also add a 21 CFR part 11
package to your lunatic or Center
software if you need to meet compliance
this add-on includes everything you need
from full sample tracking data
authenticity and user accountability
with electronic signatures so include
features such as system and experiment
specific audit trails electronic
signatures like I just mentioned and
data integrity checks
so get the quantity and quality of your
sample in the same experiment with
stunner stunner allows you to learn more
about your biologic by measuring both
concentration and dynamic light
scattering on the same set of samples
using just two microliters you have the
flexibility to get the information you
need with sizing and concentration
colloidal stability experiments or you
can even brew your own application now
with the right tools getting accurate
concentration measurements can be a
great thing but measuring accurate
concentration and knowing whether your
sample is still good can be a beautiful
thing
thank you all for tuning in and I'd be
happy to answer any questions you may
have
thank you Lisa for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button
Lisa will answer as many questions as
time permits now the first question is
what needs to be done to prepare samples
for b22 Cady experiment
yeah so a preparation for a BT 2kd
experiment is actually pretty
straightforward all you need is your
protein stock solution which is
typically less than 20 mix per mil for a
b2 to kV experiment so once you have
your protein stock solution in hand you
can simply dilute that and to make at
least 5 other concentrations of protein
and then you would also measure your
blank and so what happens is the
scattering intensity of that blank is
subtracted from the samples so that you
can get the scattering intensity of the
protein itself and so the center
analysis software will calculate the B
to 2 values based on that information
along with the scattering intensity of a
known standard so typically a DLS
calibration standard needs to be run
every 6 months and that value will be
used in the equation for B to 2
so aside from just measuring the
calibration every six months you can
simply load your sample sample solutions
your dilutions with your blank and then
you know hit go and then you'll have
your B - 2 KT results now what's nice is
that concentration is measured at the
same time so you don't have to actually
measure the concentration before the
experiment because it's collected
simultaneously
excellent and are both of the covets
used for making the measurements
yeah so both of the Cubist's are used in
the measurement so the two qubits are
the 0.1 millimeter path length you vet
and the second one is a point seven
millimeter path link you get so the two
cubits are both used in the uv-vis
measurement but the second one the point
seven millimeter path length is used for
the DLS measurement
and if I've already measured the uv-vis
of my samples can i reanalyze the data
with the equations I want
yeah absolutely so the homebrew
application on stunner makes this really
easy so the homebrew application is the
is wearing you can actually enter your
formulas so the equations that you want
to analyze your UV vis data in a
particular way and simply all you have
to do is if if you've already measured
the UV vis you can actually recalculate
that dataset with your own custom made
homebrew application so it's really easy
to toggle you know your data set between
recalculation to get the information
that you need
and what is the minimum protein
concentration you need for adls
measurement
so pretty much across the board for all
DLS systems the minimum concentration is
0.1 MiG's per mil of lysozyme and so for
Center this this is the same so you want
to make sure you're at least at point 1
mixed per mil of lysozyme for DLS
and if I want to measure samples in
different percentages of glyceryl do I
need to take the viscosity into account
for DLS
yeah so both the viscosity and the
refractive index of the solvent play a
part in the calculation of the sizing
the particle sizing of your sample and
so if you have you know special solvents
or unique excipient in there that can
cause changes to the refractive index or
viscosity quite drastically from that of
water then those values you may want to
want to enter to to make sure that you
have accurate particle sizing but
Stunner makes this actually really easy
for you in that you can enter all these
values in to preset analytes and buffers
and so simply let's say you didn't know
the value for your viscosity for a 30%
glycerol sample what you can do is
measure the samples we measure the
samples anyway and then once you figure
out those values either from published
references or you actually measure the
value you can recalculate the data set
with the new viscosity value to get more
accurate sizing results
thanks a lot and is this instrument
equally as useful for crude samples
comparison being to for bio
yes so this a little bit different
because Center is a standard uv-vis
reader so there's no binding that's
occurring within the chip like there
would be with a forte bio instrument
however we do have the unmixed
applications so for protein so for like
crude lysate samples for example you can
use the unmixed application on center so
it's called the total protein
application and what this does is it
actually subtracts other types of
impurities away from your sample so
things like salts detergents azide
things of that nature and nucleic acids
however it won't separate different it
won't separate a mixture of proteins
within your sample so all proteins will
essentially absorb at a 280 and will be
reported together because there's no
binding that's occurring on the chip
and looks like we're going to have one
last question what is the dynamic range
in comparison to the slope spectroscopy
yeah so the the slope spectroscopy is
equal to the solo vbe so we have two
path lengths that you know enable pretty
good range for for that our high-end for
examples is 250 mix per mil so it's
pretty good with with respect to the IgG
excellent well I'd like to once again
thank you Lisa for your presentation and
I'd also like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions we're also like to
thank our sponsor Unchained Labs for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through july 2019 leverage will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye